leaving comments on content has now
become a marketing function there are
Brands growing more from their comments
than from the creative they put out and
so that's one of the things that I would
have a major strategy on threats one of
the most famous viral things I did for
my community was I called it the dollar
80 strategy based it on when you leave
your two cents you know that's saying
I'm gonna give you my two cents I told
people in Instagram six seven years ago
the concept was hey you want to grow
leave 90 meaningful comments a day on 90
other big accounts but don't spam and be
like follow me you have to leave value
that's why it's two sets you know if
you're Wendy's you're snarky as we've
seen their tone of voice if you're a B2B
company you're being educational there's
a lot of ways to play I think people
default into humor too often not
everything and everyone should be funny
being civil being kind being clever
being strategic being self-deprecating
every brand here should be doing more
self-deprecating content it would make
most of your marketing dramatically more
palpable